what is going on here citizens of the rejection
it's time for the final episode of One Piece
season one I want to say thank you to all who
have joined us on this journey thank you Aaron
for being here with me are you excited Aaron
I am born excited I'm I'm so excited I could
keep it short okay you've got somewhere to be
geez you're taking too long me happy we are
we this is dragon out this is dragging way too
long Dragon Ball Z this is dragging out please
we gotta we gotta get some tracking you know we
got I'm not dragging it now you're trying to drag
it up dragging it up we're saying dragging like
15. let me look up what it means to drag it out
really leave a like on this video that'd be very
much appreciated also be sure to subscribe and
click that notification Bell for something that we
might cover in the future bowling through action
watch long we're singing with your own copy
available for super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page thank you to all have joined for just
one piece alone but we cover several things over
there exclusively with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included let's get to it
thank you
oh it's her getting her tattoo it's like branding
yeah she's just a kid when she got it too dang man
[Music] damn you got any tattoos no you pay
me 100 million Berry when you're able to pay
you and your town will have your freedom map
collector wow she had the money and then he just
stole it right from her and I like a pirate who
used to keep my promises no you don't it's a liar
oh [__] dang it really burnt that [__] down
the chico told us about your sacrifice we didn't
know can you ever forgive us there's
nothing to forgive I was kind of a dick
this is my fight no hours this is our
fight right guys finally I got to cut
something but how are we going to be our long
we saw what he did at bratia every creature
has a weakness even bulletproof ones you
don't have to do [__] I won't hesitate
oh that's a cool one I would get each one of these
logos each one of these title sequins as a shirt
they've all been pretty cool I have received word
of pirate activity at Coco Village what what oh
Pirates there is a new Chrome in these parts led
by a ruthless killer the pirate in a strong hat
Savage
would be stupid enough to attack us
yeah let's go [Applause] let's
go oh yeah yes yes oh hell yeah
oh nice
way to go buddy
yep sounds about right great camera work
all around yeah all around very well shot
stop wearing them when I was
12. I never cleaned it up they
just stopped love it there
is for a rainy day
what a big blade
oh yeah this guy Spire fire
spitter great shots again nice
I loved it this Zoom board is like a
shredded like an anime action [Music]
that was nice it looks like someone's
backyard [Laughter] rich man's pool not me
you you could have been spared taking your place
right by my side yeah the deal you betrayed me
overboard maybe for giving me a hundred million
like what nothing can stop me from taking the East
blue and every other sea after that pirate king
not even flinching could you
have used her so effectively yes
mm-hmm
yeah they're always bleeding
yeah he's holding on to the blade
yeah she's a person with wants
and dreams of her own guy
anyone else who tries to hurt other people or
alongside the hell are you talking okay I wasn't
there for those events get out of here Nami but
Luffy I got this you can escape round two are long
have the motivation of friendship now
so Swift maybe you should take a break
maybe you ought to get back in the kitchen
Luffy needs us oh great that
was dope you don't know what
Luffy needs I know he needs my cooking you
mean putting two slices of bread together
trust me I can help you
guys win this thing oh gosh
yes yes oh so much better than I
even remember I'm gonna get out
of here kiddos I'd love to make things
right but it's time to exit stage left
I guess not
oh damn
oh unless you probably put some stuff on
it there's no way you're bleeding that
much this has to be a trick too bad little
one just when we're starting to have some
fun you really he really hunted him
down yeah he really singled out USA
hey Netflix what happened to the element
of surprise my skin is tougher than bullets
maybe you should try one of my new patented
fire rounds I don't catch fire maybe you don't
but the bottle the alcohol does whoa
nice the Great Captain uza
fails another notorious villain
the first time I've ever done something
okay you strike down my brothers
okay against the might of my fish your fish man
karate fist in 3D three-dimensional fisty cuffs
kick him in the face Angie
oh okay this guy's good
also wouldn't draw get his
swords fixed damn it let's go
yes oh
[Music] [Applause] that's a
great new teeth yeah he is
gross no thank you
[Music]
damn it is Karate kicks can break a ship
skill that's nothing you should have seen
Seth's kicks when he found the next show
in the creme brulee I can't nothing [Music]
no
burn the maps burn them maybe I
can't beat you but I can destroy
everything you've built what
you talking about Willis burn it
[Music]
nice outsmart him Army is a fool to
ever faith in such a weak and Patriots
[Music] God I love him so much yeah
[Laughter]
what a reference what a call back
follow me
[Laughter] straight through
that's great she's like who's
this guy who's the new guy [Music]
that was so cool burn the maps
let's just smack the it's a lantern
lanterns thank you smack the Torches
oh
my God yes
that was the last thing I expected [Music]
Luffy slingshot your way out of there yo
that's crazy he's fine he's made out of rubber
right I love the consistency
of Zorro and Sanji still with
their hands in their pockets yeah so cool always
you are our friend
Let's Go
the music too straw hat for life baby
let's go I even got Zorro smiling okay okay
he's going to be king of the Pirates
I love it love it love it love
it I mean our Long's not dead
though oh probably not I'm gonna need
these recipes too you should really
write a cookbook it could be talked
into offering some private lessons
nice try why do none of these women want
to sleep with him I don't understand
he's Charming I don't understand
[Laughter] pulled my trusty slingshot
like single-handedly defeated
arlong and his deadly crew
With a Little Help all right cheers we're
gonna have done it without him Luffy man
hooray I Love Lucy all right the Marines
oh [__] I forgot about them arrest them
I saw the story Cocoa Village you have
your orders Cadet no no finally you do
realize there are severe punishments for
disobeying direct orders disagree with
those orders sir join the Pirates join them
me too yes I called it from the first episode
wow last chance Give It Up
it's not really my thing hmm
you're gonna fight him do you
have powers too he's gotta
I mean did have he did throw that that ball
earlier I don't want to fight you Grandpa
fighting me your entire life damn
come on man you just defeated R along you can do
this I think Grandpa's stronger than our long got
that old man shrinks just crush the whole village
Luffy just give him one of those claps give him a
little Thunderclap or do that kick again do that
super kick because I trained you better than this
you did
oh he's gonna slingshot himself yeah
[Applause]
yeah I didn't think that was gonna work I told
you you aren't ready you can hit me all day long
I could do this all day but I'm never giving up
on my dream and I will find the one piece Pirates
is it every episode [Laughter] yep yep
have it your way lower your weapons
you're stubborn just like me but I know who you
are boy I just needed to make sure you knew it
too what a long journey right to find that
out he's the whole Marine Fleet Texas grants
he wasted government money to test his grandson
wonder if that's going to cause the Marines to
question his leadership because he just let
these Pirates go they've been chasing for
like six months I can move forward with my head
held high that's why you always want it right
I'm sorry I didn't understand
the sacrifices you made for me
now open that over your thigh you
know that Citrus you want the juice
so messy cyan it was a napkin or something I hope
you'd be proud of me she was always proud of you
how's your own the new tattoo worth it do you
really have to leave I do need to go no matter how
far you go you will always have a place here to
return to this will always be your home hell yeah
my God there's lyrics oh [Music]
Citrus pinwheel that's what her
mommy made her I have an orange
tree do you eat oranges like that I love
oranges I wanted to show you something
hell yeah that's that's a lot of berry
it's the highest bounty in the East blue
you're a wanted man now
exactly what I wanted you just wanted to be
wanted the whole time I guess this is goodbye then
goodbye means forever we're
just done with Kobe now
be a good Marine be a good pirate oh they
both will be they both will be they can
navigate the Seas Together live in
your dreams what a beautiful thing
unless movies wanted posted not just Luffy
this is stupid this is going to make things much
harder with that price on your head every Bounty
Hunter and that useful will be cunning for
you season dose then it's a good thing we're
not staying in the East blue going to the
West Blue we're going to the Grand Prime
oh hey hey and the bird too
yay we're shanks [Music]
oh they're all coming back all the
characters we met along the way
up
[Music]
then all right buggy yep buggy yep
and then our uh our mustache a guy
that killed a little [__] myself if you
don't I will team up the Fire Woman yeah
team up what about the other guy what about the
butler guy the odds of all three of them in the
same room are not likely right now that's Season
Two Season Two I'm ready to accept my punishment
following orders doesn't make you a good Marine
it's following your code all men have their own
brand of Justice and you both followed yours hmm
nice oh yeah my training methods have been called
the worst kind of punishment you gotta train us
yourself well you want to get stronger don't you
learn how to fight yes teachers not a
villain he's not I was not expecting that
um I want to show people that rogano azaro isn't
the only one that knows how to use swords oh I
need a new haircut the old Chef was right it is
your turn they're the right age ah our guys back
that's the butler oh he's gonna be teaming up with
the butler huh oh no no shakes Shanks come on lads
we're in the presence of a mighty warlord of the
sea show a little oh respect see you monkey see
Luffy's want to post her please I recently ran
into someone who might be of interest to you
Thursday
you really did it no way it's Lucy he's a
pirate he's a captain wait which one is usop's
Dad I don't know bring out the reserve booze
boys thought you were hungover Shanks Gosling
I can't wait till they reunite I'm so excited
oh hell yeah Journey thoughts anytime you want
tangerines not oranges a bit odd but I like
it a little bit of home with you I love it
perfect we actually have something for you too
is it what I think it is
[Music]
the Jolly Roger beautiful how'd they do that
without him realizing I love it
love it love it love it [Music]
ill adorable son of a [__] right [Music]
[Music]
good River or a canal or something but it
doesn't make any sense these elevations
show a mountain I mean how can a river go up a
mountain no how can a river go up a mountain hmm
draw that oh hands on deck for a cast
off ceremony stuff ceremony full circle
barrel and now they're about to oh my
God hero shot Arrow shiny or blue oh
hell yeah their childhood dreams I'm
gonna be the world's greatest Swordsman
what do you want Mommy I'm gonna draw a map of
the world okay all right what do you want usab hi
I'm gonna find your dad I'm gonna become
a bright Warrior of the sea that's right
yeah I mean that one's more achievable than
the other ones but yeah man you got this oh
let's put our feet in what do you want
to do Greg I want to reach 1.4 million
subscribers there it is there it is the one piece
those are another it's a tease or
what's the cotton what's to come
what's to come we don't know who's this Feller
uh-oh burning burning Luffy's thing this is
when an ending explained ruins shits for us
thank you well cool as non-watchers of the
anime I don't know what that was about the
anime right there all right let's skip
to it skip to it let's just get in it
okay that was fun all right Aaron let's look at
the time and then we got to get you out of here
10 minutes I'm gonna wrap this [__] up buddy
what did you think I loved it I love the entire
show I love this episode I thought it was
incredible yeah we started with the stuff
with Arlon or arlong and seeing Our Heroes
finally come together working together and
doing all the cool things the heroes that decide
to be a team do from usab's moment taking down
the the one fish guy to Luffy taking down arlong
to Sanji and uh Zora working together it was so
cool to Kobe realizing his Arc and The [__] kind
of getting his Arc too and then Luffy coming full
circle becoming The Wanted pirate he always wanted
to this was like dream fulfillment for everybody
involved or all of our characters you know that
they're on our their journey to become the heroes
that they really want to be and I thought it was
great you know it's it was a live-action anime
that succeeded at being a live-action anime and
it did it with flying colors you know it got us to
endear the audience to these characters and their
they made a believable and yeah man it was just
it was just so much fun it made my heart so happy
and I am thoroughly invested in one piece after
years of people telling me to watch this thousand
plus episode show I haven't seen all thousand
plus episodes I haven't even seen the anime but I
have seen this and I love it and I understand the
hype now it was it was great and yeah I I love
seeing I think the thing about this show that
made it so great was this this persevering heart
of dream fulfillment and teamwork and realizing
that you can do anything with little help or
you can do anything with a dream and a vision
and pursuing that dream pursuing that vision and
perseverance yeah I think overall this was one of
the most fun I've had watching a show in some time
uh because it had heart it had incredible action
it had beautiful choreography it had
beautiful set design incredible music
and yeah it just passed on all colors for me I
think maybe some things could have been fleshed
out a little bit more or rather like given some
time I still think usab could become more useful
in the future because it kind of feels like
they're like they had his two episodes they're
like we'll figure it out eventually but you know
he's he's he's kind of funny um but yeah I think
everything else really uh really worked for me
even the turn of Garb being not so bad of a guy I
was like okay I can get behind this not what I was
expecting but hey I'm with it I'm with the journey
and yeah I think for the time being that is what
I have to say about it I really really enjoyed it
Greg what did you think well I think that
this show was excellent on all accounts
it got me thinking in the Final Shots of like
what does one piece mean or like what is the
interpretation I can at least have of it and
I feel like they're all like pieces to this
one Unity you know this whole team the straw hat
Pirates each like it's not it starts off as just
Luffy's show and then as it progresses it's like
every one show yeah so it's all these pieces that
all become one even though they're searching
for a thing called one piece I love the idea
of unity and that's so much of what it's about
is the the power of companionship the power of
cooperation the power of friendship the power
of belief in others the power of self-belief
it's just a lot of very positive messaging uh
throughout it and it even thematically tied in
with his grandpa which surprised the [__] out
of me uh out of everything that every turn that
happened the most unexpected one I thought
for some reason the grandpa might let him go
I didn't expect it to be the reasoning for what
happened there oh yeah and like not even because
it's straight up had this like shift where it
wasn't even jarring it didn't even feel like a
cop out because the whole season is like [__]
he's the villain he's the Baddie he's a bad guy
the big bad the ultimate and then he reveals
what's really up and he doesn't even like punish
the other two no instead finds like oh that's the
kind of spunk I'm looking for you know and it all
fit with the character yeah it didn't go against
the character it's like well that's kind of uh
I normally I'm left here baffled and kind of a oh
you kind of just undermined a lot and to hear him
like no this actually lines up with everything
yeah at all tracks like he's a tough [__] and
everything I'm not saying like he's like a nice
person um but he's not the villain you know and
I or at least right now right and and I like that
Nuance too that they have of understanding that
not all Pirates are bad and not all Marines
are bad people you know and um that it's all
about like the power of the individual you know
the uniqueness of that one person who can really
make a difference and it's a lot of that too is
like the one person who can make a difference so
I thought a lot of there's a lot of great strength
here and uh yeah you know incredible fight scenes
all around I like the camaraderie with everyone
I like the back and forth of Zorro and Sanji
um everyone had a character Arc here pretty
much kind of you saw but everyone everyone here
had like a really clear character and it gets
you excited for what's to come uh for for the
future for these guys and setting up the stakes
of it while not also feeling like they're rushing
just to set up season two like I still feel like
I got a complete Journey here of them becoming the
Assembly of this team while looking for more to
come like I think it's a near perfect season one
you know there are some sometimes in the directing
where I was like nah I feel like they might have
like overshot it a little bit like I mean just
like shoot him like maybe this looks like not as
I don't know you know what I don't even want to
bother nitpicking I don't even want to bother
honestly I don't like it was it like the end of
the day a word is hard on a sleeve throughout
and and it's there's nothing like it there's no
other live action show like it there's nothing
like it and uh I've seen you know me either yeah
so uh I think it was I think it's excellent unique
and from what I understand a pretty damn good
adaptation as well and um I I can't wait for the
next season because I feel like whatever things
I would have nitpicked about some of the ways it
was shot or maybe looked or maybe they're like I
didn't really have the budget to do this certain
moment here or there again I'm probably a nitpick
because it was so [__] rare when I thought it
I feel like with the amount of success the shoe
had it's just you're gonna lucky so much it
already looked great it's gonna imagine like just
how much more refined it's gonna look in season
two just how much they already threw a lot of
money on this first season imagine how much better
it's gonna look in season two better some of the
cinematography will look with some of the makeup
in this in the visual effects and all that like
for the vast majority already looked amazing I'm
like oh man it's already gonna look better than so
yeah I I I'm very very excited I think this was an
excellent experience and I hope that one with
the hope the weight's not too long because you
know the Netflix shows can take a while plus the
strikes and everything oh yeah [__] [Laughter]
oh yeah it's gonna be a long time uh but
the weight I think will be worth it and
um music excellent everything around I feel like
if you just take all everything we've said about
every episode that's the whole series review
yeah that's the whole point and I think uh
some of those things I was missing from our long
in the last episode kind of gave me more of that
here that I was looking for um so yeah everything
all around it was great guys um thank you all for
being here thanks Aaron for being on the stream
with me uh it's pretty sure you're sticking around
I know you got something to really get through
that you paid for a long time ago thank you guys
so much again and uh keep a look out I'm sure
there's going to be something else great to cover
um all right well I won't be I'm done
oh we're done thank you guys bye [Music]